let's be honest nobody ever likes the
guy in charge hey folks I have the
pleasure of being able to welcome back
to the show
Stu bagful and in fact you'll even get
to see his actual face this time and
we're gonna be talking about both in the
current and the macro sense of Doctor
Who history as a whole the fact that
fans always seemed to have it out for
whoever's currently running the show it
was just kind of a fairly laid-back
conversation there's gonna be a bit less
structure than I usually do but I had a
good time with this conversation and I
think you might too let's go to it
so this was your idea to talk about yeah
I thought it would be fun to try and go
into the psychology of why Doctor Who
fans tend to hate the showrunner no
matter who it is because this is this is
a persistent problem it's um Chris
Chibnall is having it right now Steven
Moffat developed it over time because
obviously you know he started out as the
golden child yeah Russell Russell T
Davies did start to develop it towards
the end of his tenure and this goes back
to the classic series as well because
jnt' was sort of sort of this massive
figurehead of derision for quite a while
because the show started falling apart
under his watch so I thought it was I
thought it'd be quite interesting
because it's it's quite obvious that
there are lots and lots of factors as to
why the show might be stalling in our
opinion but we always seem to pin it on
the showrunner yeah that's really weird
well and it's it's worth pointing out
that us having this conversation and
noting it as a phenomenon because I do
agree with you it does seem to kind of
be the case that it does not mean that
there are not legitimate reasons to
criticize whoever the showrunner was at
the local soco's but it does always seem
like
fan estimation of them goes up once they
are no longer in the job oh yeah because
um yeah yeah because Russell T Davies
did get quite a lot of criticism back in
the day and then around the time that
Stephen is getting quite a lot of I
noticed people starting to talk about
him as if he was as if the users were
like the golden days which you know they
kind of were to some degree but at the
same time it was much more noticeable
when Stephen started to get a lot more
criticism online you you know what my
favorite type of thing that when this
happens is is when the new guy gets
criticized for stuff that the old guy
also got criticized for but they act
like the old guy didn't do that so yeah
I when people would because I obviously
this is a danger for me to go down this
rabbit hole but obviously people some
people like to hit the agenda drum and
they really liked hitting Moffatt with
that towards the end when characters
like Bill got introduced and so often
when I would see that they would talk as
if that didn't happen in Daviess era and
whether or not you think there is agenda
pushing I remember Davies era and how
much he was accused yeah he did joshing
that exact same thing because of
characters like Jack Harkness but when
they started accusing Moffatt of that
they acted as if that had never happened
under D yeah it's yeah yeah it's not a
new thing it is like it is like people
try and try to try and pull this - um
sorry Jemima swearing on your thing
I'll bleep it okay yeah yeah it's some
it is like people they seem to think
it's a new thing they they're just sort
of using old reasons that we had to hate
the showrunner and thinking that they're
new for some reason I think part of it I
think part of it's that I wonder if it's
just part of it is well here's me being
really cynical fans are just never happy
and yes it is true what they would like
to imagine that they were once and so
when once you can segment something off
into specific eras you
can suddenly put on the nostalgia
goggles for the older segments even
though at the time you still weren't
happy but nobody likes to think that
they've always been miserable but the
most the thing the way that you the way
that you're saying is I've been on
YouTube for a while criticizing Steven
Moffat and going so over-the-top with it
and now adopts to the Christian lira and
I made that video that I made recently
talking about how I'm kind of bored with
the Christian era and I kind of missed
them off our era even though I got so
over the top with it you you dragged
Marvin this nothing like we are not
immune from this criticism because you
dragged Moffat a lot I did I did but I
never did it out of spite
I always did it as in you know Steve
amorphous brain is so much it's like the
size of the planet or something that's
that's yeah that that's me just taking
the piss I never really saw him as like
oh he's like this is like this big evil
gory but that's the thing people will so
make up reasons to hate the showrunner
because I remember there was this one
story um I can't remember where I saw it
um it was people were saying that a
parent apparently Moffat was blocking
Torchwood coming back huh which was
which was just uh which was just Steven
Moffat has never had anything to do with
Torchwood it was before his time and
it's not like he's head of BBC program
planning or anything it's just he's this
big figurehead in the show that we don't
like at the moment
so say something something we don't like
like say Torchwood not coming back
that's his fault somehow he's not an
executive he's I mean he's a high-end
guy in the creative department but all
that means well yeah well all that means
is he gets a long leash when he gets
when he gets put on any given project
but that doesn't mean he controls what
goes on elsewhere yeah exactly so I was
I was caught I was kind of I was kind of
amazed when I saw that story first come
out there I was just like why are people
there's got to be something about this
ecology of the Doctor Who fan that makes
them think things like this I'm not sure
it's strictly speaking restricted to
Doctor Who though cuz I mean I don't
know this fandom as well I will grant
but I can look at something like Star
Trek and while you don't have the
showrunner thing it does seem like every
new series of Star Trek
while it's airing is not as good as the
one that came before and that and then
in hindsight you'll start to reevaluate
it when the next one comes out and it's
a similar reaction yeah and then
ultimately everyone just decides ds9 was
the best anyways but it gets muddy yeah
I think I think he's just that I think
it's just that level of love and passion
that comes with being a fan being a fan
of such a massive from geeky properties
like Star Trek and Doctor Who I think
it's it's it's sort of like you're
defending a loved one or a spouse from
it sort of like you're defending a loved
one or a spouse from abuse you know what
his level of love that you have for this
you have for this show that you think
when that you think when someone's not
treating it right that then you start
acting out well that can go over the
line in cases like I just mentioned with
my own thoughts good well see the thing
is I think there's there's a certain
amount of incentive to find someone to
blame if you're not happy with something
that you like and that's true and
because like the this is this is a you
know ancillary and it's a it's an
analogy but I think it kind of fits I
don't know if you gain much
I don't think Lee yeah I thought
sometimes getting back into it I don't
really but I used to and because I care
about it as a medium and I think it's
there's a lot of cool things that can't
be done with it I still keep on top of
what's going on but you look at
something like what's going on with the
company Bethesda right now which is the
company that makes
the eldest close games and following the
fallout yeah yeah right now their output
is so bad and has been consistently in
the last few years that people are kind
of forced to reassess whether or not
their early stuff was even any good and
that's a real painful thing to have to
do yes if if you're looking at something
boy I used to love this and I don't now
it's much easier to be able to say I
don't like it now because of this person
who's in charge now
as opposed to reverse engineering that
and realizing oh the things I do I can
now have kind of always been there yeah
oh yeah I was watching that reminds me
of um H bomber guys some
control-alt-delete video where he's
talking about this need that we have to
find someone to blame and he was talking
about gamers looking at a specific
figurehead in a company to say that your
attitude is the problem you're the
problem and not think you know but like
the bigger picture and that there are
systemic issues yeah people to make
these mistakes I mean sometimes it's
systemic or sometimes in terms of the
creative property you maybe there are
just elements of it that you you as a
person no longer enjoy that doesn't mean
they've changed so like I'm not gonna
name names cuz I don't wanna I don't
want to bad-mouth anybody but actually
just today there was a YouTube channel
that I unsubscribed from and then the
person who ran it they were doing stuff
I've been following them since they were
doing stuff on Newgrounds back in like
2002
oh that's and I've always felt
oh I've always loved their stuff but
what I realized when I unsubscribe today
like I felt bad because I was like is it
has it changed has it gotten worse but I
had to sit down sort of take us that's
when I realized no it hasn't changed but
I have yes ten fifteen years ago
I was primed for this and I got
something out of it he hasn't changed
what he's done but I've grown out of it
it doesn't mean that doesn't negate the
enjoyment I had at the time but it
doesn't mean I kind of can't take
enjoyment from it anymore and if I if I
didn't sort of do that sort of check
myself I could have just gone ah he's no
good anymore it's like no he's he's
doing the same stuff at the same quality
it's just it's not working for me now
yeah I have I have been wondering that
myself with this whole talk throwing my
toys out of the pram over Chris Chibnall
it's I have been wondering that myself
over whether it is me that's changed but
then again I start I'd stuck with Doctor
Who all throughout Steven Moffat as much
as I was as much as I was complaining on
the internet about him I'd stuck with it
I didn't like the direction the show was
going in that March bird there was just
sort of something about it where I just
felt like I have to stick around and say
things about it well it is different
with Doctor Who versus other things
because with because of things like the
the regenerations and getting whole new
actors and whole new supporting cast and
basically effectively rebooting the show
in universe every couple of years that
does mean that the show by necessity to
some degree does clearly change over
time so it's not quite the same thing as
what I was saying with that youtuber was
like well he's doing the exact same
thing as before but I do mean us the
same person yeah yeah but I do wonder if
to some extent there is at least a
little of that if for some people
there's they might have grown out of
some of the fundamental aspects of
Doctor Who but they don't want to admit
that and so it because it becomes easier
to say no the problem is the show's now
bad yeah I mean yeah yeah because you do
appreciate different stuff as you grow
older like I've been watching the show
since oh well knew who since it started
of course in when I was like 14 and yeah
because I don't I don't think I would
have appreciated something as mature as
and cent for example when I was 14 I
mean I would have probably appreciated
it that though on the level of their
being Doctor Who but just not on the
level that I appreciate it now or on to
where I'm sitting where I'm seeing more
deeper meanings in it so I suppose so I
suppose Heaven Sent was like that thing
that that thing where I felt the show
had grown up with me to a certain degree
and then and then and then season 11 is
so far removed from it I feel like I've
been watching the show in I feel like
the issue with the way that I
transitioned from season 10 to season 11
is I've been watching it as this
continuous show from start to finish so
I sort of feel like I'm more entitled to
make judgments about I don't know don't
know if that's me being a bit big-headed
but I don't know I don't know whether it
is me that's but me me having grown out
of the show cuz it does do lots of
different things all the time
I mean look but you know thinking about
the video that you put up recently some
things have changed in terms of the
approach and the feel of it the core is
still the same the concept is still the
same yeah most of the visual iconography
is the same but there is still a
different feel to it
that comes and that comes about with
each new showrunner you know with each
new showrunner I mean it's the most
noticeable aspect yeah the nice
showrunner
I wonder if part of it is just that and
that I'm trying to think of a way to say
this that doesn't sound overly
judgmental but I wonder if part of it is
that in terms of what was attempting to
be done and the tone and the themes and
the mood I feel like kind of like what
you said the show kind of matured going
from Davies to Moffat because Davies was
a little bit more camp a little bit
sillier Moffat it felt like it was if it
felt like growing up a little bit
because it was dealing with
didn't always work but it was trying for
heavier themes and more adults stop yeah
like yeah like Doug Fir make me at the
end of season at the end of season a
that was very dog exactly but then with
Chibnall the overall vibe is if I was
gonna say it's closer it's closer to
Davies in terms of feel and tone and and
weight to it and again you can decide
whether or not that's to your preference
but I do wonder if part of it is that it
feels like a backslide like imagine if
you read the seventh Harry Potter book
and it was totally closer to the second
than the sixth it's like wait a minute
we know yeah true it's night and day
those two yeah we were we were heading
in this trajectory but now it feels like
we've gone back and I do think dr. shows
Doctor Who is a show that should be
allowed to do that but I do wonder if
you've been watching continuously if it
feels like a backwards step and an
undoing of evolution since there was a
there was kind of an overall trajectory
between the first two showrunners yeah I
think maybe it's just a weird weird
setup and weird format like you were
saying like the show is essentially
rebooted every few years or so maybe
that sort of gives rise to this idea
that we should hate the new showrunner
because you know people have a hard time
dealing with change and and I mean
that's it I mean that's just true and I
suppose I suppose it I suppose it
happened over time for Davies and Moffat
because you know familiarity breeds
contempt I suppose because because
because
Moffat he was our golden child for a
couple of years then people then people
started hating him and it got fast far
too over-the-top to the point where I'm
hearing rumors about stuff that he's
supposedly done which he's obviously got
nothing to do with I one chip that chip
no hasn't had that hasn't had the
honeymoon periods well I think the thing
is I think that's action I feel like
Chibnall if we were to try and track
this as a trend chip know might actually
be more
standard and the fact that the other two
had a grace period might be more the
exception it's just numerically that's
not the case here what I mean by that is
Davies had big benefit of the doubt
coming in because he brought the show
back we wouldn't have had it at all if
it weren't for him
and given that there had been known new
I would say proper episode since 89 and
no nothing visual since 96 people were
just happy to have it back at add at
anything close to the old show at all
and so he he gets a grace period for
that and then mod it because he had
written such strong stuff during the
Davies era he got a grace period based
on that
whereas Chibnall because none of the
thing he's written for the show but none
of the things he's written our are near
are as beloved as things like the empty
child or blink and so he doesn't get the
grace period and I wonder if we'll see
as things go on and we get whoever the
next showrunner is and fingers crossed
whoever the next showrunner is after
that because I don't want the show to
end
but if we'll find out that the grace
period is the exception rather than the
norm yeah yeah cuz I don't think I'm I
mean nobody still was around today so I
could say I couldn't say about J and T
but yeah there were reasons for um
Russell and Stephen to have those grace
periods I mean I suppose cuz when
Russell brought the show back there was
no guarantee that it was gonna be a hit
so I mean lots of people were quite I'm
not really sure if this is going to work
about it yeah yeah because that yeah I
mean I mean people I mean as the TV
landscape changed around Doctor Who's
because it was so massive that it stayed
on that stayed on the air and yeah you
know it can't it can't it kind of felt a
bit anachronistic in the landscape of
British TV in the 80s I saw I think I
think it is just familiarity breeds
contempt because because we're so close
to this property because it just it just
inspires such strong feelings in people
therefore therefore we don't want to see
it mistreated yeah I guess
the and this is not a question that I
had thought I was gonna ask but you know
what let's let's try and end on on a
little bit more of us okay know if you
were to pick the next showrunner cuz
yeah regardless of what it should know
those one more series or two or has been
secretly fired and we haven't been told
that's not the case but some people
claim that regardless at some point
there will be a new showrunner do you
have a pick I would not wish that's on
anybody okay and I'm this fandom and how
and how chip know it's been except it's
I would not wish that on anyone
okay let's let's set the jackasses like
you and me aside firm yes yes talking
what they could bring to the show um I'm
gonna be greedy and go for Charlie
Brooker oh really
that is very greedy because you know me
grown up at the show wants it to do
darker more mature things like
heaven-sent yeah charlie cooker so okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna give you that you're
inspiring me to give you a greedy pick
which I know is impossible so then I'll
give a realistic one
so my greedy pick would be Neil Gaiman
oh yeah that is very creative but but he
has said after Good Omens that he's not
gonna show run anything ever again so I
know that's that's not even an option so
realistically I I'm still surprised that
the gig did not go to Toby Whithouse
yeah I'm surprised as well I really
enjoyed being him and quite a lot
I actually didn't love it all that much
but definitely tonally it is closer to
Doctor Who I feel like the episodes of
Doctor Who he actually wrote are better
than ship knows and I mean chip know ran
a show to we were in broadchurch but
broadchurch is a very different beast
whereas I feel like you could look at
something like being human and go okay
he's quite solid yeah yeah III knew they
were gonna I kind of knew they were
gonna
chippin although because he's the one
who's had a massive success outside of
the show that's true and and ratings
were dwindling under Moffatt so the BBC
would want to play it safe I mean and I
suppose that's fair but I hate that they
did that cuz I do and that was something
you mentioned in your video I do feel
like that is ultimately sort of the
issue that I have with Chibnall
specifically not with everything that
went on with series 11 and there are
some individual episodes that I do love
I think it takes you away as phenomenal
but part of the reason I love that
episode so much is because it's not safe
but Chibnall and a lot of the series
overall and especially the episodes he
wrote are very safe so so safe yeah and
if the rumors that it's gonna be old
like classic monsters this time round
he's probably played it safe again as a
nice yeah he's played it safe in a
different way and yeah it's like it's
actually again it really are it
irritates me because a lot of on paper
the broad strokes of series 11 were
things I wanted I knew I wanted
fewer two-parters I didn't want an
overarching story I didn't want
returning villains and they did all that
stuff and yet you know entitled fan that
I am I still wasn't happy yeah we're
just never gonna be happy I know it
really is look like it's like they took
my checklist of things I wanted to do
did all of it and still presented me
with something I wasn't happy with I am
yeah I am the epitome of the unplaceable
family mate maybe maybe in five years
time we can come back and watch it again
and you think you know what maybe it's
not about hey you know what fingers
crossed
yeah cuz yeah yeah cuz I happy I have
been enjoying your um revisitation
videos of new episodes and I did forum
loss last of the Timelords and ended up
enjoying that quite a lot in hindsight
like that there are I still have issues
with that but I have found that going
back even episodes that I didn't like at
the time and still don't like I can
usually find at least one thing that I'm
like okay there is that yeah and I
suspect if and when I get around to read
series 11 I'll probably find that there
too yeah as I said familiarity breeds
contempt it oh you get you get a bit you
get up in a distance and you can
reevaluate it with fresh eyes so I
thought I think that is that is why
people hate the showrunner maybe maybe
Chris Chibnall maybe Chris Chibnall will
find his fan base in five ten years time
maybe hey stranger things have happened
yeah so wrap up then yeah sure why not
do you have anything to plug besides
your channel Twitter
oh yeah that's where socks are myself I
exist do you do you though do you rail
is anyone really exist I'm not sure
we'll have to check that okay yeah I
would double take your figures on that
yes yeah
are we are we really gonna get into
existentialism that should be what we
should be what we do after doctor after
doctor who and all these franchises
existential questions who are we what
are we why what why anything what have I
been doing with my life
oh god yeah the Internet all right well
thanks so much for this this was I'm
really glad that we thank you for
allowing me to take part in your chat
yeah people people have been I don't
know if they've been pestering you
they've been pestering me to have you on
again for a while that's nice and I'm
very hesitant about so thanks a lot
[Music]
thanks everybody for tuning in if you
don't already subscribe just do bag poll
you should do so by clicking the link
down in the description also while
you're down there you can like subscribe
leave a comment with your thoughts on
anything that we talked about buy merch
find the link to my patreon that's super
helpful also you don't have to do any of
it
I'd appreciate it certainly but at the
end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings sometimes
with the guests and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]